I must have absolute silence Stanley the
publisher of Marvel Comics has probably
been in the comic book business longer
than anybody on earth
he claims that Guinness is going to put
him in the Book of Records but that's
not really true is it
well they very well might you know as I
had mentioned earlier I think that I've
probably written more stories that have
been published than anybody who's ever
lived I started I was about seventeen
and a half years old I heard that this
publishing company was looking for an
assistant and I didn't know that this
had anything to do with comics I just
knocked on the door and I said anybody
want an assistant and they walked me
into this little room with two men named
Joe Simon and Jack Kirby and they were
turning out the comics for the company
and they said they need help after a
little while they needed some editing
they there was some dialogue bits that
they didn't think were good and they
said hey Stan can you rewrite these so I
rewrote them and after another little
while I was ending up writing stories
for them hey everybody is Charlie you
guys may have seen this morning that
Stan Lee passed away at the age of 95 so
I wanted to make a video memorializing
him
there's no figure in comics that's quite
so great they'll never be anyone like
him again that's had such a great impact
on the comic book industry he'd been
working in comics almost continuously
for his entire life even though not all
of it was at Marvel he became the public
face of Marvel during the 70s that's
when you started to see him stomping
around Hollywood in the early beginnings
of what became Marvel Studios many many
years later Kevin Feige had a really
nice post where he said no one has had
more of an impact on my career and
everything that we do at Marvel Studios
then Stanley Stan leaves an
extraordinary legacy that will outlive
us all our thoughts are with his
daughter his family in his millions of
fans Thank You Stan excelsior
for those of you that don't know about
excelsior if you're wondering why that
was his catchphrase and why he said it
so much this is the quote that he gave
about it I used to have a lot of
expressions that I would end my comic
book columns with hang loose face front
true believers nuff said and I found
that the competition was always
imitating them and using them mostly
talking about DC Comics tongue-in-cheek
so I said I'm going to get one
expression that they're never going to
know what it means and they won't know
how to spell it and that's where
Excelsior came from and they never did
take up on it thank goodness so he was
saying that he was trying to come up
with a catchphrase that nobody would be
able to copy because it was so utterly
specific to him as a person also kind of
funny to hear him take a dig at DC
Comics during that like trying to do
something that they won't be able to
copy at the other big publishers most
people know him from his comic book work
as a child my first introduction to him
was actually through the spider-man
animated series in the 90s when he
started to appear in more and more
cameos I said to check what if his skin
turns green excuse me I'm looking for
some guy named Stan Lee what man Pam
hold my calls for a while I think I
finally got that was the beginnings of
what will become like the most prolific
cameo actor in the history of comic book
movies and movies in general I think
he's done over 65 cameos at this point
I'll talk about some of my favorites in
a second this other quote from Kevin
Feige also does a really good job of
explaining his relationship with Marvel
especially in the later years when he
become more of a mythic figure in Marvel
Studios had blown up and become the
biggest comic book studio in the world
he says stan has always been very
gracious with all of us at Marvel
Studios and very encouraging despite his
persona on stage Stan was very humble he
was not the type to come in and tell us
how to be but he encouraged us to follow
his lead
take Black Panther we would talk about
the importance of the movie and what a
brave thing it was for Walt Disney
Studios to spend this kind of money on a
film like this but look at what Stan Lee
and Jack Kirby did in the 1960s with the
character creating him at the center of
the civil rights movement so you have to
remember that all the accomplishments
that Marvel have made today Stan Lee
Jack Kirby Steve Ditko and the
spider-man character they all did that
stuff decades and decades ago a lot of
the people who worked with him talk
about his incredible work ethic he was
actually a child of the depression he
grew up and lived
through that so he was always driven to
look for new work even where none
existed even when he was just working on
regular comics he was always busy doing
something that's why you see him in his
later years in his 70s 80s in 90s
obviously the last couple of years still
being super active on the comic book
circuit but you may not know that
Marvel's early start in Hollywood during
the 60s 70s and 80s is largely due to
Stan Lee's efforts after he rose to the
role of publisher and became more the
public face of the company he started
stomping around Hollywood trying to get
them to adapt their comic book
characters most of the early success
that he had was in getting TV shows
greenlit particularly animated TV shows
spider-man there was a show called the
Marvel superheroes which is I think
their first genuine TV show that aired
his brief segments during The Electric
Company TV show so it's like the
Simpsons getting their start as shorts
during the Tracey Ullman TV show their
first real big live-action hit
understand Lee was that live-action
Incredible Hulk series during the early
80s so naturally his first cameo was
during that Incredible Hulk series it
was 1989 as a jury member during an
episode called the trial of The
Incredible Hulk
[Music]
his first movie cameo came many years
later as the hot dog vendor on the beach
during that first x-men film I still
think that my favorite Stan Lee cameo is
probably from guardians of the galaxy -
as the agent of the watchers just
because you know he has 65 plus cameos
this one cameo canonized as all the
others as him being the same character
anyway before I was so rudely
interrupted at that time I was a Federal
Express man hey fellas hey wait where
are you going hey you were supposed to
be my lift home how will I get out of
here hey IG I've got so many more
stories to tell Oh guys oh gee fine
right
the bartender's all like yeah crazy
stupid fire are you Tony
dank yes this is this is Tony stank
[Music]
what's the matter with you kids you've
never seen a spaceship before
you know I guess one person can make a
difference
enough said so Lord of the Ring style
one cameo to rule them all
for those of you that are asking he
already filmed cameos for the upcoming
three Marvel movies for a Captain Marvel
for Avengers 4 in spider-man far from
home we don't know what the cameos are
going to be we just know that he's
already done them let me know in the
comments though what's your favorite
memory of him and what's your favorite
Stan Lee cameo we can only imagine if
his Avengers 4 cameo is gonna blow all
the others out of the water
Marvel will probably end up adding
special tags at the end of the next
couple of movies memorializing him and
then in future movies after that finding
cool ways to include Easter eggs and put
him in the movies without actually
putting him in the movies what I'm also
hoping is is that when they dropped the
Avengers 4 trailer later this year
they'll have a special little tag at the
end memorializing him just in honor of
Stan Lee you can click here for another
Stan Lee cameo video that I did where he
talks about his favorite cameo and
there's a big super cut and click here
for my new Toy Story 4 trailer video
thank you so much for everything Stan
Lee you had an amazing life and we will
miss you dearly
[Music]